ever wondered if the world around us is
just a mind-bending illusion with the
technology explosion in Ai and
computational Neuroscience this reality
seems closer than ever imagine a future
where we can actually tweak our own
reality using Cutting Edge brain science
but what kind of Neuroscience would we
actually need to develop to make this
happen brainwashing neurosimilation and
neural interfaces these are actually
technologies that are being developed
right now but how far are we in Sci-Fi
movies and books Technologies are taken
to the extreme creating different
dystopian Futures and although some of
them are quite far off some of them have
been spot on and what these movies do is
that they push our imagination to the
limits of our beliefs so in this video
series I want to Deep dive into
different movies that actually use
Neuroscience that I believe could become
reality in the future so the first movie
I want to talk about is the Matrix this
is a cult classic and if you haven't
watched this watch it right now because
I will give applied some spoilers in
this dystopia fuchsia Humanity finds
itself trapped within the confines of a
simulated reality known as The Matrix
drafted by sentient machines it serves
as a distraction from the Grim truth
humans are being used as an energy
source our protagonist a computer
programmer named Thomas Anderson Alias
Neo uncovers the shocking reality of the
Matrix he teams up with a group of
rebels determined to overthrow the
machines and free Humanity from their
control so Neuroscience actually takes
the center stage in The Matrix the film
revolves around the idea that our
perception is being controlled by the
Matrix and that the Matrix has a direct
control over our brains and shows us
different versions of reality so in The
Matrix the machines use electrical
impulses to stimulate the brains of
humans in The Matrix and this is
actually a concept called neural
modulation or neurostimulation so
neuromodulation is a concept at the
heart of The Matrix the machines use
direct electrical impulses to stimulate
the brains of humans creating Vivid
sensory experiences and this idea has
actually been popularized in philosophy
primarily and that's the concept of the
brain in a fat so imagine that you are a
brain suspended in a fat of nutrients
Rich fluids with electrodes attached to
your brain to stimulate sensory
experiences the electrodes are connected
to a computer that can create and
manipulate virtual reality environments
which are fed directly into your brain
in this scenario your brain would
perceive the virtual reality as if it is
real and you would have no way of
knowing that your experience were not
actually happening in the physical world
now this definitely raises some
interesting philosophical questions
about the nature of reality and if we
can believe that anything around us is
real but what I actually want to think
about is if this could actually happen
if we take the loss of physics to be
real right now in our lives so instead
of creating the whole world let's tackle
this problem step by step so the first
step would be to create one experience
that's not out there in the world by
direct stimulation of our brain and
actually this is right now possible so
one example of a technology that uses
stimulation of the brain directly to
give rise to some kind of sensory
experience is a visual prosthetic so
visual prosthetic involves using
electrical stimulation to activate the
visual cortex in the brain which is in
the back for people usually who are
blind and creating the perception of
visual images that are not necessarily
there so the visual prosthetic consists
of two parts an external camera and a
tiny implant that is a surgically placed
or on the retina for example or directly
on the visual area of the brain and
using this we can actually restore the
site of some blind people to a certain
degree it's still not perfect but this
is just one sense right so could we
actually then also create the experience
of a whole world being around us and
this is definitely more speculative of
what is possible right now so one major
concept that is being embraced right now
in Neuroscience is the idea of embodied
cognition so cognition is embodied when
it is deeply dependent upon features of
the physical body of an agent that is
when aspects of the agent's body beyond
the brain play a significant causal or
physically constitutive role in
cognitive processing so in general right
now in Neuroscience It is believed that
we cannot really detach the brain from
the body because they have both
co-evolved over time to work in tandem
in such specific ways that if we detach
the brain from the body we would
basically need to build a new similar
body to give rise to the same
experiences but if you have a different
opinion please let me know down below
because it's still debated also amongst
neuroscientists if this could be
possible so in The Matrix they also use
a neural interface in the movie the
characters can Enter the Matrix by
plugging themselves into a neural
interface that directly connects their
brains to the simulated reality so this
interface is essentially a brain
computer interface maybe you have heard
of it these bcis and bcis at the moment
are actually quite commonly used so I'll
show some examples here but one example
that I personally really like is that in
November of 2011 this Japanese company
developed this neural wear created a
pair of supposedly mind reading plush
cat ears and they were called Neko Mimi
and they would react to the wearer's
emotional states and then that could be
shown to the world and it's actually
really fun if you look at videos of
people wearing these cat ears and I do
have to say of course these are not very
accurate they're based on EG but the
link between EG signals and emotions is
quite weak and it's really hard to from
a very broad EG signal get a very
specific thought pattern for example but
what could happen in the future is that
right now EG is on the top of the scope
but you could also open up the scalp and
put the BCI directly onto the brain and
this is for example being developed by
companies such as neuralink but also in
a university it's already used with
epileptic patients and this has
definitely more potential because the
signal of the brain isn't washed out by
the skull so the last Concept in the
movie is the idea of brainwashing and
the brainwashing aspect in The Matrix is
a little bit more under the surface and
it lies in the manipulation of human
perception and the suppression of their
awareness of reality the machines
control the information fed to
individuals within the simulation shape
shaping their beliefs memories and
experiences so in general I find the
idea of brainwashing really interesting
I think right now it's a little bit out
of fashion this term but it was
popularized in the 1950s by an American
journalist named Edward Hunter and he
used this term brainwashing to describe
a new form of psychological intervention
that he claims was being perfected by
certain enemy States and Hunter argued
that this conglomeration of ideology
technology medicine and psychological
Sciences could be used to launch an
onslaught on people's mind so these are
very specific words but I want to dive
into the idea if Neuroscience could
actually be used to brainwash people so
one of the most basic ideas of
brainwashing is the suppression of
memories and certain feelings so the
first thing that we would want to do if
we want to suppress a specific memory is
locate where this memory is located in
the brain but if you know a little bit
about Neuroscience you actually know
that memories aren't located in a
specific part of our brain they're
actually distributed over different
areas and networks in the brain the
formation storage and retrieval of
memories involve different brain regions
working together two main areas in
memory processing that are quite known
are the hippocampus and the cerebral
cortex and you could of course think
maybe I could just destroy these regions
and then I would automatically suppress
the memory formation of people and that
is sure you would suppress the memory
information of people but they would
also basically not be able to function
in the world anymore so I think this is
a little bit too extreme but something
that has been done in animals actually
which I find quite interesting and it's
still unknown if this is possible with
humans but that is the suppression or
manipulation of memories through
optogenetics so for example two recent
Studies have shown that it is possible
to weaken or even erase memories
associated with drug drunk use in rats
which reduces their drug-seeking
behavior when recovering addicts see
things like drug-related items or
reminders of dark use can trigger a
strong craving and make them more likely
to repress in these studies aim to
disrupt this process of memory
reconsolidation which is our ability of
our brains to strengthen and store
memories when we recall them but this is
usually done only during the
reconsolidation process and it isn't
really clear if after this
reconsolidation has been done which is a
way more distributed process if we can
then still alter these memory states by
a very specific Neuroscience technology
I would actually also love your opinion
if you think any of these Technologies
could be brought even further than where
they are now and if a reality such as
created by the Matrix could become a
true reality that we would be living in
also if you have any movies or books
that you love that touch up on the
concept of Neuroscience in sci-fi I
would love to read or watch them so put
them down in the comments below and if
you could choose the blue or the red
pill which one would you pick I think I
know my answer